Siamo troppo
forti che schifo Adesso vi faccio vedere
io che cosa significa disturbare Tutto
il giorno nuovissima Challenge Bulli
S contro
popolari contr secchii Sì V scola Ciao
io sono Eh io sono William e noi siamo i
più popolari della scuola D'altronde
veniamo da due famiglie ricchissime Anzi
adesso arriva il papi con la Porsche io
sono più popolare
[Musica]
selfie e noi siamo Anita e Julie Team
secchione Sì quando mi arrabbio non si
salva nessuno quindi state attenti E a
me piace tantissimo leggere e scrivere e
infatti ho qua con me il mio nuovissimo
libro La città stregata agli
investigatori del mistero è appena
uscito in tutte le librerie online Mi
raccomando andate a prenderlo anche voi
e questo è il premio finale di chi vince
la Challenge vincerà la Challenge il più
bravo a scuola e ora lo custodiamo qua
al sicuro e io sono Billy il bullo E io
sono Frank del team dei bulli Noi siamo
del team dei bulli e ovviamente io sono
il capo Scusa no sono io il capo No ma
come tu il capo sei così basso sono io
capoo io CAP
per poter vincere la Challenge dobbiamo
studiare tanto sì Iniziamo ma tanto a
noi piace un sacco studiare quindi
stiamo qua in libreria e iniziamo a
leggere qualche libro vediamo se ci
aiuta sì Ehi ciao sono l'emoji di Anita
e è un gioco per te Prova a lasciare mi
piace entro 5 secondi 5 4 3 2 1 tempo
scaduto ci sei
riuscita Allora vediamo un po' questo
[Musica]
libro c'è la cacca che schifo che schifo
che schifo guarda ho trovato la
cacarello che cosa Ma è uno scherzo Chi
è
[Applauso]
stato L'altro il pors con la
scorre questi scherzi mi ricordano
qualcuno m
ma li hanno messi in tutti i libri Maca
Maca Maca guarda guarda guarda che
schifo Ma cosa Saranno stati i bulli
sicuramente
Uffa Che cos'è questo non possiamo
studiare Adesso hanno nascosto degli
scherzi in ogni libro andiamo da
un'altra
parte Siamo troppo forti SCH sono i più
belli di tutto il mondo esatto ma tanto
noi che ce ne frega delle Challenge
tanto poi il libro lo rubiamo Sì lo
dobbiamo
rubare Però secondo me gli scherzi li
meriterebbero anche i popolari andiamo a
vedere cosa stanno faccendo i popolari
Eh i secchioni facciamo gli scherzi a
tutti
andiamo forza William vieni a fare il
selfie Certo che è difficile essere così
popolari A chi lo dici tutti che ti
fermano e ti chiedono foto è veramente
impossibile Beh di certo non Popolare
quanto me cosa vuoi saperne occh non
rimanere accecata con la mia penna d'oro
Sai cosa ci renderebbe veramente
popolari Che cosa il libro di Anita Sì
con quello guadagneremo un sacco di
follower Sì cavolo immaginati noi due e
la foto con il libro al centro sarebbe
fantastico Allora impegniamoci facciamo
i compiti così possiamo vincere il
libro troppo
semplice
basta Io ho finito per oggi io non ho
più voglia diretta No
direi ma chi ci ha conciati così non lo
so togliamo subito questa
cosa Adesso perderemo tutti i nostri po
Già me lo immagino una carriera rovinata
dobbiamo per forza vincere quel libro
per recuperare tutti i nostri po dai
finiamo in fretta
Ciao sono l'emoji di Anita sono qua per
ricordarvi che è appena uscito oggi il
mio nuovo libro La città
stregata Se non ce l'avete ancora andate
subito a prenderlo perché i primi che lo
prenderanno riceveranno il regalo il
poster con me e Merlino autografato da
me con dietro l'alfabeto segreto con cui
condivideremo tanti messaggi assieme
prendetelo subito devo sbrigarmi per
questo tema devo scrivere almeno 45
pagine solo 45 io ne scriverò
150 così tante ma allora io ne devo
scrivere di più se voglio vincere il mio
libro La città stregata io devo
assolutamente vincerlo È troppo bello
voglio averlo tanto lo vinco
[Musica]
io
un
dizionario mi aiuterà un sacco per il
tema che sta scrivendo anche a me devo
averlo
subito no lo prendo lascialo
io Dai lascialo a me No lo voglio io ma
mi serve per il tema e anche a me Se è
per questo Dai allora facciamo così ce
lo dividiamo prima io però eh Va bene
dai prima
su Dov'è finita la mia penna
Eh che
schifo questa non era la penna che avevo
io
prima ma c'è una cacca sono stati i
bulli
sicuramente Proviamo a scrivere con
queste
almeno
Che schifo Hanno l'inchiostro puzzolente
Ma dobbiamo comunque continuare il tema
perché dobbiamo vincere il
[Musica]
libro Siamo troppo
forti # troppo imbarazzante # odiamo i
bulli # disagio Aggiungi Ma come si
permettono a noi più popolari che poi
Ripensandoci il libro potremmo meritar
natural siamo i più conosciuti della
scuola Esatto ci spetta per diritto
dovremmo andare Daita e farcelo dare
libro Hai perfettamente ragione andiamo
[Musica]
forza fai quello che faccio io Ciao cara
che cosa deve essere l'odore dell'imp
opolar No questo è
veramente non fa niente Senti riguardo
al libro Oh sì sì sai vorremmo a una
coppia Ecco tu sei così brava sei famosa
come
noi Che dici se ce lo fai avere
gratuitamente ovviamente ma come lo
sapete che per avere il mio libro La
città stregata dobbiamo vincere la
Challenge solo il vincitore potrà avere
il libro eh Ma noi ci abbiamo provato ma
ci hanno boicottato in tutti i modi noi
popolari Penso che a noi spetti di
diritto oltretutto Beh anche a noi Bulli
Hanno fatto degli scherzi però stiamo
comunque continuando a scrivere il tema
quindi mi dispiace ma solo chi vincerà
la Challenge vincerà il libro ma guarda
che secchiona questa che sta continuando
a fare i compiti davanti a noi popolari
non si è permessa neanche di
salutarci Patetica che secchiona che
antipatici questi popolari Mi dispiace
ma come vi ho già detto solamente Chi
vincerà la Challenge potrà vincere il
Ah il libro non non c'è più Ma dov'è
siete stati voi a
rubarlo assolut
non faremo mai una cosa del genere e poi
con tutto il patrimonio che abbiamo
potremmo
[Musica]
comprarcasa essere per forza loro i
bulli Sì andiamo subito a cercarli Sì
presto
Ah non ce la faccio più e basta voglio
solamente fare il mio
testo Beh a quanto pare questo si è
trasformato in un altro mistero da
risolvere proprio come nel mio libro La
città stregata infatti nel mio libro c'è
un grandissimo mistero da risolvere che
potete provare a risolvere proprio voi
Infatti se non ce l'avete ancora andate
a prenderlo le leggetelo e Provate a
risolvere il mistero e All'interno c'è
anche un alfabeto segreto ma è facile
capire chi è stato a rubare il libro
mancano solo loro all'appello i bulli
Esatto andiamo subito a cercarli Aspetta
faccio una diretta così sanno tutti che
sono stati loro recupereremo tutti i
nostri follower così Ok
andiamo Ah È bellissimo questo libro
possiamo già risolvere il mistero lo
voglio leggere tutto questi di là stanno
ancora studiando quelli stanno ancora
studiando scrivendo il tema e noi ce
l'abbiamo già il
libro ma è l'alfabeto segreto no È
incredibile pensi a quello che sto
pensando io possiamo bruciare la scuola
ma che cosa stai dicendo Con questo
alfabeto Noi ora possiamo comunicare
senza che la maestra sappia che cosa
abbiamo scritto
Senio e questa è una frase per voi con
il libro potrete tradurla eh vi
consiglio di farlo perché è una bella
dedica per
voi
Vai lo sapevo che eravate state voi a
rubare il libro Sì siamo stati noi ma
col cavolo che ve lo
ridiamo no dovete ridar celo subito
invece perché lo avete rubato non è
vostro vi devo dire che eravamo in
diretta e tutto il mondo Adesso lo sa
cari follower avete sentito qui da
davanti abbiamo degli impostori che
hanno rubato il libro adesso i nostri
milioni di follower sapranno quello che
avete fatto Siete voi i cattivi Esatto
quindi ridate celo
subito che paura i
follower piango piango sono un secchione
sono
[Musica]
popolare Ora
basta 149 pagine 149
una me ne mancava per vincere tutto e
avrei potuto vincere il libro Ma no voi
dovevate disturbare e ancora disturbare
non ce la faccio più adesso vi faccio
vedere io che cosa significa disturbare
Tutto il
[Musica]
giorno venite qua così imparate a fare i
Bu Abbiamo recuperato il libro ma chi ha
vinto la Challenge Allora forse noi
siamo i più famosi no ha vinto la
Challenge la persona che ha scritto più
pagine nel tema e quindi Julie Sì lei ha
scritto un sacco di pagine hai vinto il
libro Hai vinto la Challenge lo sapevo
che avrei vinto Ehi e voi se ancora non
avete il mio libro La città stregata è
ora disponibile online in tutte le
librerie correte subito a prenderlo Sì
ho vino ho visto ho
vino
l